if berries can cry it's basically just
like the tears why I only have one hint
of berry tears today we're going to be
ranking spikes ulcers yes we are and I
am scared to death I mean I've tried
them they had on white claws at work a
couple weeks ago I am a lightweight so
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna be drunk by
the end of candolyn we're gonna have to
taste these and then best out of six
okay so first can is cape line and I
have black berry mojito and I actually
drink mojitos so I'm kind of I'm
interested I couldn't help but notice
this has the most calories out of all of
them which hopefully it's a good sign
that means that they put a little extra
flavor in here I will say this cape line
I've never heard of yes are all very
illuminating
okay I'm hopeful for these it RA smells
a lot like blackberry Cheers
oh I like it it tastes like candy it's
this tastes kind of like a margarita
I had like a box of these I would think
it was like kool-aid you know I could
see that the nice little sparkle here
could be refreshing on a warm day I have
high hopes for this one to have to say
the aftertaste of this one does taste
kind of like Christmas but the first
flavor does taste like a margarita like
the black bear it comes in so strong and
then also just fades away into like
carbonated water try it do you wanna try
this one
oh yeah mines way better than yours oh
here's this so much better I'm gonna be
generous I'm gonna say that this is
maybe a four I know it could get much
worse than this
so there's room for two at the bottom
that's a two for two yeah we'll go with
four four or Smirnoff time enough
Smirnoff I've heard of I've not had this
beverage but I feel like smear enough
knows what they're doing right nine
decals on this one which flavors you get
for that one I got pina colada is good
did you get a cranberry line this is
also a berry lemonade what's your funny
I got a pina colada
classy I think I was right about smear
oh these are all gonna taste about the
same oh that's a silly drink this
doesn't taste like anything that's not
bad yeah the fruit flavor blip pina
colada is actually a lot smoother
imagine that on ice I'm like a boat but
not like a yacht cuz we're broke so I
would say for me this one's like a three
we'll go with three on this one I agree
Oh maybe we can push the cape line back
to three and then put this one at two I
fine with that I think it's the one but
we'll go with two third one is truly now
I've heard of this one I've never had it
but this is I think one of the more
popular ones
wildberry with a hint of black cherry
yeah it's plural yeah while berry
I only have a singular hand this one's
not bad I think your smells better
though oh this one smells stronger no
actually what this smells really yummy
to me yeah yeah no I can't taste
anything
oh you're drunk it really is just a hint
I'm not really getting a lot of like
berry flavor it just tastes like
carbonated water with like a hint of
something sweet six five five I'm gonna
rank this on five I think five is yeah
I'm glad we left room at the bottom
right because truly was on the way
Charlie five five i noon I knew only Son
sips okay here's what I'll say I enjoy
this art direction here I like that it's
made with real juice I didn't see that
at first that is nice I don't think the
other ones were made with real juice
this feels like classic almost retro
like sunshine happy day at the beach
kind of thing I'm into the branding here
and then it's got a cute little cute
little watermelon this is really good I
don't care for it you don't I think it
might be our first pick disagreement huh
no no no it definitely has a much
stronger flavor and I kind of like it
it's it doesn't taste like watermelon oh
it tastes more like cucumber than
watermelon this tastes like someone
dissolved a watermelon Jolly Rancher in
a Lacroix I guess I go for has a grown
on you do you not like it
I'm mostly just thirsty this one has
been the best out of all of them so this
is our new three it grew on me a little
bit wild basic classic like cucumber
peach which I enjoy the creativity there
I like the branding like this was
definitely striking a chord with my own
it isn't the best smelling of them's
okay oh you can smell the peach this
smells like a margarita it's almost like
a peach ring you know like the lime salt
that you put on margaritas like if they
literally just put lime salt into
sparkling water I don't say this is
probably the five so should we bumped
Shirley back to six yeah
let's do it is the hearts can this be a
sick I'm physically putting it at the
far end so now it's white claw I'm super
excited something happened over the
course of two months where white car
took over the world I think it still
lives in this wonderful space of irony
the marketing blitz for these top-notch
these became insanely popular overnight
cultural phenomenon how many have we
seen about me manic and I like to think
that whoever drinks those drinks it
ironically for the culture so mine is a
raspberry flavor a natural wine oh no oh
god that's a six for sure this is my
favorite so far
it's okay I maybe it's just a flavor
let's swap all right this one was worse
than that one oh yeah oh this one is
yeah I'm like I get it now it's number
one believe the hype yeah
these are sixes yeah we can trade back
no I'm keeping this final rankings
coming in last white claw it does have a
cool name they all have kind of cool
names I think we can agree wild Basin is
hot bathwater number five truly truly
also not advanced number four wild
basins tastes alright problem was that
this one is so bad and that one is good
so it pull hold it down wears it Cape
Fear Cape on line this one's getting off
easy here if anything this should be in
the wild Basin territory number three
High Noon sunsets I think this one
should have been higher because I think
it was better than capable this one
actually has flavor to it
that's Jason I thought this one was
gonna be the worst one and this one
surprised me that loves Smirnoff
they know what they're doing from the
Haitian days but also like if you are
gonna buy Smirnoff just buy the friggin
bottles goal of Smirnoff what else yeah
you're welcome cape line cuz you barely
beat out I knew
hi high noon big fan of the can big fan
of the product
I just appreciate the fact that it was
like subtle and smooth so the number one
specifically this one the pina colada
wow this smells like summer now our new
Lord and Savior Paul crazy bastards dude
they made it they made the best hard
seltzer well these are our rankings from
worst to first step yourself up to a
senior and off pina colada nobody's too
cool for Smirnoff I think white claw
kind of nailed it I mean like how often
do you get something that actually lives
up to the hype Smirnoff I don't care
what you say I don't care what you think
you got the irony factor and also flavor
you know I can barely make sentences
right now I am focusing real ha alright
we'll finish that cam what
[Music]